how celebs they love to dress up for
Halloween but sometimes sometimes their
costumes have people feeling a certain
type of way every year there's one
celebrity who sparks controversy with a
Halloween costume and happy Halloween
today well it's not so happy maybe for
Kate Hudson she's getting some heat over
this photo this is Kate and a group of
friends dressing up as members of the
cult featured in Netflix's docu-series
wild wild country you might have seen it
it was a huge hit this year members of
this organization wear a lot of red
that's Kate in the middle and it's a
documentary about a controversial guru
and his followers so Kate captioned the
photo quote don't be worried about the
future live this moment so totally that
the next moment that comes out of it is
golden hash tag wild wild country but
commenters are not all about it one said
quote this group committed bioterrorism
against my hometown this was a really
really poor look another said quote
maybe this choice was just not good
maybe try again next Halloween well let
us know what you think of Kate's costume
was it too much or does it touch on a
big moment everybody was obsessed with
this documentary tweet us a TT live next
up Sean white
okay you might remember this he is
dressed as simple Jack that's a
character from the movie Tropic Thunder
which came out 10 years ago and that
character was a character that had an
intellectual disability of course Tropic
Thunder was a comedy but it was
controversial then controversial now and
sean has now apologized the olympian
says quote i owe everyone in the special
olympics community an apology for my
poor choice of halloween costume he says
quote it was a last-minute decision it
was the wrong one now again the movie
came out in 2008 at the time Ben Stiller
played an actor who played the character
simple Jack and Tropic Thunder and Ben
Stiller is actually now weighing in on
Twitter about Shaun White's costume he
wants to remind people that Tropic
Thunder was actually boycotted 10 years
ago when it came out because of the
character he says he apologized then
he says the idea was quote to always be
making fun of actors who were trying to
do anything to win awards and he says
look Shaun White apologized so did he so
should celebrities be forgiven when they
crossed the line with their Halloween
costumes tweet us guys we want to know
your thoughts on these controversial
looks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]